[Music]  do you believe in love at first sight  yeah I do  so here's the new guy boy  your thief won no no no maybe  no you want to do in life  I don't look beautiful yeah yeah visor  remember men are simple kiddie and  yourself a man with sad eyes man's got a  smile and leave you with a heart full of  hurt  [Music]  making you pay for what you heard me  there she is  you ever been to San Francisco course  why is it nice  [Applause]  [Music]  is it just been tough for my mom with me  this happens next time you're out we all  got our place in the world kidding  it's not true isn't it what you do how  would I love how I look you know you  don't thank you  no you don't  [Music]  it was an accident that's all  don't look like no accident  seems like not a whole lot of people are  happy  [Music]  I think people need to learn to  appreciate things more  [Applause]  because if you look at it a certain way  life is just so amazing  [Music]  you